President Biden is defending his
handling of the documents Mark
classified found in two locations he
used while out of office the president
told reporters yesterday that he did
nothing wrong
I think you're going to find there's
nothing there I have no regrets on
following what the lawyers have told me
they want me to do it's exactly what
we're doing
Nancy Cordes is at the White House with
more Nancy good morning
good morning Michelle this was the first
time that the president addressed the
controversy since a special counsel was
named to investigate last week the
president took one question about these
documents and as you saw he was a little
bit defiant even as he read from some
prepared notes he said there's no there
there he said the American people are
worried about other things and that
these 20 or so classified documents were
simply filed in the wrong place he added
that his team did what it was supposed
to do by alerting the National Archives
and then turning the pages over to the
justice department now he did not say
why the White House decided not to
publicly disclose the existence of these
documents found at his home and at his
former office until after CBS News broke
the story a couple of weeks ago the
special counsel who has been appointed
by attorney general Merrick Garland is
gearing up for his investigation and
should get underway by the end of the
month President Biden said that he is
looking forward to fully cooperating
with the special counsel and he also
said he's looking forward to quote
getting this resolved quickly Nate
Nancy thank you